[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 j'espère que
vous allez bien nous sommes le jeudi 19
janvier voici le programme à la une de
l'actualité cette journée de
mobilisation nationale contre la réforme
des retraites de nombreuses yvelinois
ont suivi le mouvement de grève
plusieurs lycées ont même dû fermer à
cause du manque de personnel dans votre
7 8 nous reviendrons sur les enjeux de
cette réforme avec deux députés
yvelinois Bruno milleniène du MoDem et
William Martinez de la nupette qui s'y
oppose starts
de recherche pour véhicules électriques
qui ont été inaugurés aujourd'hui par
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
alors comment recharger sa voiture quel
est le prix Grégory canalet journaliste
de la rédaction de TV 78 vous dira tout
ce que vous devez savoir sur ces
nouvelles bornes et puis comme
d'habitude le jeudi à l'approche du
week-end nous vous donnerons nos idées
de sortie dans les Yvelines nuit de la
lecture spectacle danse rendez-vous avec
notre journaliste Ludivine canard et le
jeudi nous consacrons également une
chronique sur le bien-être animal c'est
avec vous à tizbaret bonsoir bonsoir
alors de quoi est ce que vous allez nous
parler ce soir écoutez je vais parler de
la carte j'ai un animal seule à la
maison ce soir et ce sera du coup tout à
l'heure vous restez bien avec nous ce
soir c'est aussi le retour du quiz avec
vous Nicolas dandry sur quoi est-ce que
vous allez nous challenge et ce soir
Nicolas je vais vous parler des
écrivains on va voyager à la fois dans
les Yvelines sur l'ensemble du
territoire mais aussi dans le temps et
donc ce sera à la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant je tends un coup d'œil
à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel le sera bien
présent sur l'ensemble du département au
niveau des températures il fera 0° à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Versailles et
moins 1 degré à Rambouillet mais le
ressenti seront aux alentours de -3 dans
l'après-midi le beau temps sera toujours
au rendez-vous au niveau des
températures comptées 6 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie 5 à Houdan et Versailles
et 4 à Rambouillet et demain nous
fêterons les Sébastien le pont
maintenant sur l'actualité dans les
Yvelines
et c'est avec vous réginera lej bonsoir
bonsoir on commence par la grève
nationale contre la réforme des
retraites qui a eu lieu aujourd'hui oui
c'est d'ailleurs l'image du jour comme
vous le savez de nombreuses union
syndicales ont appelé à la grève contre
la réforme des retraites ce jeudi et
dans les Yvelines pour se rendre à la
manifestation des bus sont partis ce
matin direction place de la République à
Paris on écoute les réactions au micro
de Julien Leroy cette journée est
importante je serai dans à la retraite
certainement dans un an un an et demi
mais je me bats pour nos enfants pour
les jeunes et pour pas qu'ils partent
trop tard quoi c'est important de se
mobiliser c'est notre avenir qui est en
jeu donc c'est normal de participer à
cette manifestation et de montrer qu'on
n'est pas d'accord avec avec cette
nouvelle réforme il y a des peut-être
une réforme à faire mais il y avait des
règles des problèmes à régler avant de
commencer à parler de reculer l'âge de
la retraite
une mobilisation importante puisque la
CGT 78 nous a informé que 15 cars
étaient partis ce matin contre 11 ans
2019 et du côté des écoles comment
étaient su suivi cette grève nationale
journée très compliquée également un
pointage réalisé ce matin sur 276 écoles
indique que 62% d'entre elles étaient
grévistes selon les syndicats et dans le
secondaire les collèges et lycées
n'avaient pas l'obligation de déclarer
leur intention de faire grève mais on a
noté la fermeture du lycée Jean Monnet à
La Queue-les-Yvelines et du lycée de
Launay à Villepreux on poursuit ces
informations du jour avec le
redressement judiciaire de l'enseigne Go
Sport le verdict est tombé ce matin le
Tribunal de Commerce de Grenoble à
placer le groupe Go Sport en
redressement judiciaire après avoir
constaté son état de cessation de
paiement en parallèle en novembre
dernier une enquête avait été ouverte
pour abus de bien social pour
information le département des Yvelines
compte 4 magasins Go Sport à Parly 2
Orgeval Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
Vélizy 2 les professeur de la famille
marquinos ont été jugés aujourd'hui
c'était à Chatou le 14 mars 2021 deux
agresseurs avaient séquestré la famille
de Marquinhos le joueur du PSG les
agresseurs avaient pris fuites en
emportant avec 2400 € en liquide de
bracelets en or et de sacs à main ils
ont écopé d'une peine allant de 7 ans
pour le premier et de 5 ans avec 3 ans
de sursis probatoire pour le second
direction trappes des baguettes de pain
ont été distribués aux personnes les
plus démunies oui et c'est l'initiative
de doucine Boo ce gérant de deux
boulangeries à Trappes a lancé le
concept de la baguette suspendue et ce
depuis 2013 il s'agit en fait d'acheter
deux baguettes dont l'une est offerte
aux personnes qui n'en ont pas les
moyens chaque mois c'est environ entre
300 et 300 baguettes qui sont
distribuées cela peut monter jusqu'à
1000 en hiver et comme l'opération
fonctionne bien c'était l'occasion pour
lui de continuer cette action dans sa
nouvelle boutique ouverte hier le Market
délice et on termine par une image notre
image du jour Régine celle de la neige
les premiers flocons enfin les premiers
aujourd'hui oui Mathilde le département
était placé en alerte jaune neige et
verglas vers 15h les premiers flocons
sont tombés en quelques minutes le
paysage est devenu tout blanc et vous
pouvez voir à l'image nos internautes
nous ont fait parvenir quelques images
de belles images effectivement merci
beaucoup Régine ralès merci à vous et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une information qui vous a marqué
près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous
la partager en utilisant le hashtag 7 8
news
on en parlait en début d'émission le
mouvement social social contre la
réforme des retraites a débuté
aujourd'hui avec une journée de grève
générale voulue par de nombreux
syndicats professionnels et pour parler
des enjeux de cette réforme des
retraites nous sommes avec deux députés
Yvelines noires William Martinet bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes députés dans la 11e
circonscription des Yvelines et Bruno
milliennes bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes député MoDem dans la
9e circonscription des Yvelines alors je
commence avec vous William Martinez 1,5
millions de Français selon les chiffres
de la CGT étaient dans la rue
aujourd'hui quel est votre réaction face
à ce chiffre
et bien écoutez la preuve qu'il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup de monde dans la rue
je crois que c'est vraiment une journée
exceptionnelle moi j'étais à la
manifestation parisienne bien sûr voir
autant de monde voir cette foule défiler
ça donne de la joie du courage de la
force en monnaie de bataille contre la
réforme des retraites alors la première
chose que je voulais dire c'est c'est
m'adresser à celles et ceux qui sont
opposés à cette réforme et qui ne sont
pas encore descendus dans la rue leur
dire rejoignez-nous pour les prochaines
manifestations vous allez voir défiler
ces quelque chose de quelque chose de
très fort et on a besoin de force
puisqu'on sait que que cette attaque
sera sera dure mais je pense que
aujourd'hui c'était aussi un grand
moment démocratique puisque nous avons
les Français qui dans leur écrasante
majorité ont envoyé un message ils ont
dit que ils en avaient marre de se faire
marcher dessus qu'ils en avaient marre
de ce gouvernement qui casse tout qui a
cassé l'école qui a cassé l'hôpital et
qui maintenant veut casser nos retraites
voilà d'une certaine cette façon nous
nous avons commencé à taper du point sur
la table et à dire et à dire non et donc
je crois que ça du point de vue de la
mobilisation c'est c'est très important
pour la suite et j'espère que le plus
tôt possible le gouvernement entendra ce
message et retirera sa réforme des
retraites Bruno Mylène pensez-vous que
ce chiffre 1,5 millions de Français dans
la rue pourraient faire céder le
gouvernement pour le faire réfléchir
a pas que je ne suis pas gouvernement
dans l'incapacité de répondre à cette
question là moi j'ai une seule question
qui me qui me ripile qui me turlupide
depuis très longtemps c'est comment on
fait pour sauver notre retraite par
répartition aujourd'hui n'est pas
financé il est pas financé par les
cotisations normalement ce régime par
répartition que le monde entier nous
envie et financé par les cotisations
versées par le travail aujourd'hui quand
on regarde l'argent qui est mis sur la
table sous les ans pour les retraites
il n'y a que 79% de l'ensemble des
retraites des pensions de retraite qui
sont payés qui sont financés par les
cotisations le reste c'est des
subventions de l'État donc c'est vous
moi le secteur privé enfin chacun
d'entre nous qui payons pour amener ce
régime à l'équilibre ce n'était pas du
tout ce qui avait voulu le général de
Gaulle donc moi je suis prêt à toutes
les toutes les améliorations possibles
mais j'aimerais surtout trouver la
solution pour qu'on sauve le système par
répartition tout en assurant un
financement stable et pérenne ce qui
n'est absolument pas le cas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas les chiffres
qui ont été avancés je vous renvoie vers
le la note du Commissariat au Plan c'est
pas 7 milliards par an
compte tenu de ce que je viens de vous
dire c'est 30 milliards par an qui sont
souvent sur l'état d'accord on paye
cette réforme elle est essentielle cette
réforme des retraites elle est
essentielle aujourd'hui
on peut trouver tous les moyens qu'on
veut on peut parler de toutes les de
toutes les choses qu'on veut il y a un
moment la seule question qui qui vaille
c'est est-ce qu'on sauve ou pas le
système par répartition après il y a
d'autres systèmes qui existent dans le
monde on peut on peut aussi essayer
d'autres systèmes si on veut conserver
ce système là aujourd'hui il n'est pas
financé de matière de manière pérenne
voilà c'est tout quant à la mobilisation
bah oui elle a été forte donc contact il
faut en tenir compte c'est évident on
s'attendait d'ailleurs à ce qu'elle soit
forte et c'est légitime que les Français
sont inquiets sur une réforme qui est
pas facile moi je la défends et je la
présente pas de gaieté de coeur ça ne
fait jamais plaisir à personne de dire
qu'on va prendre des mesures de ce type
là mais c'est un petit peu en
responsabilité qu'on dit aussi aux
Français si vous voulez que vos enfants
aient des retraites et des retraites et
des pensions de retraite qui
correspondent à ce que nos retraités
touchent aujourd'hui il faut trouver un
système de financement pérenne pour les
30 40 prochaines années qui viennent
Martinet pourquoi est-ce vous vous êtes
contre cette réforme des retraites
alors d'abord je m'inscris en faux avec
le premier argument qui a été développé
par le collègue millième
selon les propres mots du président du
comité d'orientation des retraites qui
d'ailleurs a été auditionné ce matin en
commission de défense il n'y a pas de
danger sur la pérennité économique de
notre système de retraite puisque dans
dans les projections les plus
pessimistes qui sont faites d'ici 2030
on serait à une dizaine de milliards
d'euros de déficits pour un total des
montants de pension qui sont versés de
l'ordre de plus de 300 milliards donc on
est à moins de 3% de déficit d'ici 10
ans et ensuite si on prend le reste de
ses projections le système va
naturellement se remettre à l'équilibre
donc la réalité c'est que cet argument
de l'urgence économique pour sauver
notre système de retraite il ne tient
pas il n'y a pas de danger sur l'avenir
de notre système de retraite ou plutôt
je vais préciser mon propos il y a bien
un sur l'avenir du système de retraite
c'est la réforme qui est en train de
faire le gouvernement puisque quand vous
durcissez les conditions pour accéder à
une retraite à taux plein ce qui est le
cas de cette réforme si vous êtes reculé
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite et
si vous allongez les durées de
cotisation pour avoir une retraite à
taux plein vous rendez plus difficile
pour les gens le fait d'avoir un bon
taux de remplacement dans leur pension
c'est-à-dire d'avoir une retraite qui
leur permet de vivre dignement du coup
l'effet mécanique de tout ça plus vous
affaiblissez le système de retraite plus
vous poussez les gens à aller vers un
autre système qui est le système de
retraite par capitalisation qui a un
système privatisé marchandisé il est là
le danger c'est au contraire si on
accepte la réforme du gouvernement et
qu'on accepte l'affaiblissement de notre
système de retraite par répartition que
là on ouvre la porte au privé la porte à
un tout autre modèle de société que je
crois les Français ne veulent pas donc
il faut maintenant faut arrêter avec
cette argument économique qui
ne tient pas et il faut prendre les
choses sérieusement parce que de le
gouvernement demande c'est de travailler
deux années de plus à quasiment tous les
Français y compris et surtout ceux qui
ont des métiers qui sont difficiles qui
les fatigue qui les usent et bien en
réponse à ça l'écrasant majorité des
Français disent non nous n'acceptons pas
cette réforme et le gouvernement mais
comme les députés de la majorité puisque
monsieur milienne vous comme moi nous
allons nous exprimer sur cette réforme
si vous dites que vous ne la portez pas
par gaieté de coeur mais vous pouvez
même aller plus loin vous êtes
parlementaire et à l'Assemblée nationale
vous pouvez la refuser vous aussi vous
pouvez dire à ce gouvernement qu'il va
dans la mauvaise direction
répondre Bruno mélienne si vous voulez
apporter
le système de retraite redevient
déficitaire il est durablement pour les
années à venir avec un taux de chômage
de quatre et demi pour cent il n'y a pas
avec un taux de chômage de 4 techniques
pour cent c'est dans un scénario
volontariste le plein emploi sur une
longue période le déficit estimé à 12
milliards en 2027 14 milliards en 2030
21 milliards en 2035 ça c'est des études
du Comité d'Orientation des Retraites
moi je veux bien que vous disiez tout et
n'importe quoi mais vous pouvez pas
mentir sur les chiffres après moi je
suis ouvert à toutes les propositions
pour qu'on le finance il y a pas de
souci mais ça c'est la réalité de la
situation d'accord premier point
deuxième point c'est sans tenir compte
du fait que l'État s'est obligation de
maintenir notre système de retraite à
l'équilibre et ça vous ne pouvez pas le
contester non plus les gens un peu
sérieux ils vont voir c'est
qu'aujourd'hui notre système de retraite
n'est financé qu'à 79% par les
cotisations et que les 21% restants et
ben les 21 pour son c'est des
subventions d'État c'est donc du déficit
chronique de l'État et ça ça représente
30 milliards par an voilà premier point
deuxième point
insister là dessus mais malgré tout je
pense pas que le président ait pris les
Français par surprise puisque c'était
annoncé dans son programme présidentiel
alors vous pouvez me dire et je
l'entends et vous le dit à chaque fois
le président a été élu de manière à
légitime puisqu'il n'a pas été lu par
pour son programme mais par opposition
Marine Le Pen ça c'est votre mantra
n'empêche que c'est quand même lui qui a
été élu président et pas Jean-Luc
Mélenchon voilà clairement donc le
président fait ce qu'il a dit vous
pourrez continuerez à continuer à
échanger sur sur la réforme des
retraites juste après mais avant on va
écouter une interview réalisée par
Julien Leroy il est allé interviewer un
syndicat le secrétaire départemental de
la CGT des Yvelines Nicolas chameau sur
sur les raisons de cette réforme et sur
les propositions que le handicat
pourrait apporter à cette réforme des
retraites écoutez
[Musique]
le gouvernement Macron promet une
réforme de de la retraite sur la
retraite avec un allongement de l'âge de
départ à la retraite de 60 à 64 ans et
une augmentation du taux du nombre de
cotisations la majorité des salariés
sont opposés à l'augmentation de l'âge
de départ de la retraite tant que Macron
n'a pas retiré ce projet le doigt nous
on continuera à mobiliser l'ensemble des
salariés alors proposer des journées
d'action de grève
au départ à 60 ans avec en financement
intégré par notamment des la suppression
de certaines exonérations de cotisations
par le respect de l'égalité femme homme
au travail c'est les femmes alors
justement valeurs c'est 5,5 milliards de
cotisations qui rentrent dans les
caisses donc la quasiment la moitié du
déficit est résolu
on a énormément de camarades qui sont
sollicités par des salariés certains
dans certains endroits c'est pas mal les
cas qui demandent comment on fait grève
j'ai jamais fait grève de ma vie mais là
trop c'est trop il faut c'est pas
possible il faut se mettre en grève pour
dire qu'on ne veut plus de cette réforme
communiquer inter syndicale qui vient
d'être établi actuellement signé par la
FSU 78 par fo78 solidaire 78 et l'Union
des étudiants est bénois plus la CGT et
des Yvelines bien entendu la discussion
n'est pas fermée on propose de
rencontrer les autres organisations
syndicales mercredi soir prochain pour
voir comment on travaille le
revendicatif dans le département sur
cette question là
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
propositions
de ma pensée sur la pérennité du
financement du système de retraite vu la
coupe démographie est vue le
vieillissement de notre population
il va être très compliqué de maintenir
ce système de répartition à l'équilibre
dans les années qui viennent il faut pas
se leurrer les subventions de l'État
pour combler le déficit chronique dont
je vous parlais vont être de plus en
plus importants donc je pense qu'à terme
il sera très compliqué de financer notre
système de retraite auquel tout le monde
tient uniquement par les cotisations
il faudra qu'on trouve d'autres sources
de financement et on en a on en a
d'ailleurs proposé au modem
notamment d'aller taper non pas
sur le capital parce que le capital est
investi mais plutôt sur la rente celle
qui reproduire rien donc on verra et
toute façon dernière chose ça va être
sur émotion Martinet nous on a demandé
au gouvernement très clairement d'avoir
une clause de revoyure en 2027 pour que
quand on sera passé à 63 ans je vous
rappelle que l'âge de départ réel
aujourd'hui des gens à la retraite c'est
62,8 ans d'accord taux de revoyure quand
ce sera face à 63 ans deux mois de plus
pour qu'on voit où on en est du
financement de ce système de retraite et
est-ce qu'on doit continuer sur la seule
clé qui nous paraissait acceptable c'est
à dire l'allongement
de la durée de travail parce que sinon
c'est les cotisations en plus ou
l'abaissement des pensions de retraite
ça tout le monde le sait depuis
longtemps donc voilà on essaye d'être
sur quelque chose sur une réforme qui
est difficile difficile à appréhender
par les gens qui peut être reçu comme un
juge qu'on soit totalement on essaye de
trouver des solutions pour essayer de
faire en sorte que ce système de
retraite là le système para répartition
soit pérenne sans trop pénaliser les
gens voilà c'est un peu notre position
William Martinez vous souhaitiez réagir
oui je réagis à l'argument qui est donné
sur les subventions de l'État pour
financer maintenir à l'équilibre le
système de retraite pourquoi il y a des
subventions d'État qui sont aussi
importantes c'est parce que elle
compense des exonérations de cotisation
sociale qui sont faites aux entreprises
et qui se sont accumulées ces dernières
années au point où nous en sommes
aujourd'hui à 150 à 160 milliards
d'euros par an d'exonération de
cotisations sociales qui sont des
exonérations qui malheureusement
profitent principalement aux grands
groupes au CAC 40 aux multinationales
dont on a vu d'ailleurs dernièrement que
d'accumuler des dividendes de record
cette année 2022 pour les entreprises du
CAC 40 le record de dividendes 80
milliards qui ont été versés donc c'est
sûr que si d'un côté nous avons des
politiques publiques qui multiplient les
exonérations de cotisations sociales
envers ses grands groupes et bien c'est
normal derrière d'aller expliquer que il
faut que l'État le comble avec les
subventions donc monsieur millième si
vous voulez qu'on travaille à des
solutions pour avoir un financement de
notre système de retraite par
répartition qui repose sur des
cotisations commençons par peut-être
arrêter une partie de ces exonérations
de cotisations sociales voilà est-ce que
les grands groupes si je parle de ceux
qui en profite le plus est-ce que les
groupes de la grande distribution
Leclerc Carrefour Auchan qui ont
énormément d'exonérations de cotisations
sociales sur les basses salaires sur les
salaires par exemple des hôtesses de
caisse des agents de sécurité des gens
qui mettent des produits en rayon etc
est-ce que c'est important pour ces
grands groupes de faire des exonérations
de cotisations sociales non peut-être
qu'on devrait les arrêter et qu'on
devrait utiliser cet argent pour
financer notre système de retraite mais
une fois que j'ai dit ça et je vais
finir sur un autre point parce que on
parle beaucoup de l'équilibre économique
tout ça c'est très important je dis pas
le contraire et vous avez vu que je
prends le sujet au sérieux mais
n'oublions pas quand même que derrière
cette réforme des retraites c'est c'est
la vie des travailleurs qui ont jeu là
je parlais d'une hôtesse de caisse donc
une caissière dans la réforme qui est
proposée par le gouvernement une femme
qui commence à travailler à la caisse
d'un supermarché à 20 ans dans la
réforme actuelle on va lui demander de
travailler jusqu'à 64 on va lui demander
de travailler 44 ans à la caisse de son
supermarché est-ce que ça paraît
raisonnable ça non ça paraît pas
raisonnable parce que c'est des métiers
où le corps est usé ou le corps est
habillé et ces gens-là ils sont
indispensables au fonctionnement de
notre société mais ils ont le droit
après une vie de labeur de d'avoir une
retraite qui soit décente et
malheureusement c'est ce qui est en
train d'enlever la réforme du
gouvernement et c'est pour ça on a
autant de français
répondre mais juste avant Grégory
canalet nous a rejoint un plateau
bonsoir Xavier une question à poser
question aux deux députés bonsoir Bruno
Milian bonsoir William martinet sur la
suite de ce mouvement on a vu une
première journée de mobilisation avec
une envergure alors la question pourrait
Martinet est-ce que le mouvement va
continuer dans la durée est-ce que vous
êtes Paris à continuer ce moment dans la
durée et pour Bruno Milian est-ce que
vous ne craignez pas justement qu'on se
retrouve vers une situation de blocage
avec une France bloquée dit justement ce
mouvement va continuer dans cette durée
où il y a martine a peut-être sur la sur
la première question
donc écoutez oui le mouvement va durer
la prochaine étape d'ailleurs c'est ce
samedi
une marche nationale qui organisait à
Paris à l'appel des organisations de
jeunesse parce que les jeunes sont aussi
concernés par cette réforme et mon
mouvement la France insoumise y appelle
donc dès samedi il y aura une nouvelle
manifestation et puis surtout
l'intersyndical va poser une nouvelle
journée de grève et de manifestation
dans le paysage et c'est une très bonne
chose parce que je n'ai pas eu le temps
de souligner jusqu'à maintenant mais il
y a l'unité syndicale contre cette
réforme des retraites et c'est une des
conditions qui fait que cette
mobilisation peut être peut être
victorieuse donc je sais pas pendant
combien de temps et quel sera la
puissance de cette mobilisation mais si
jamais on se retrouve dans une situation
de blocage du pays je le dis très
clairement le responsable du blocage du
pays c'est le président de la République
qui décide d'imposer une réforme
impopulaire ce n'est personne d'autre
le mot de la fin
de chaos dans le pays c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon enfin bref passons je veux
revenir sur deux trois petits points
quand même la différence entre vous et
moi c'est que la caissière j'ai pas
envie qu'elle reste caissière toute sa
vie donc je vais lui donner des étapes
pour qu'effectivement elle évolue dans
sa carrière et pour faire de sa carrière
quelque chose de moins pénible et de
pérenne je vais vous prendre aussi des
exemples puisque vous en avez cité
certains il faut que je le fasse aussi
vous omettez de dire que dans ce déficit
structure de 30 milliards il y a aussi
des subventions versées pour compenser
les régimes spéciaux
je vous entends pas leur demander
effectivement de faire un effort
d'accord c'est pas que les patrons il y
a aussi des régimes spéciaux deuxième
point troisième point et ça on a du
boulot à faire on a du boulot à faire
ensemble là dessus en plus c'est ça qui
est extraordinaire c'est que c'est pas
totalement abouti et je dis franchement
sur l'emploi des seigneurs il faut qu'on
retravaille moi je veux qu'il y ait plus
d'étapes au cours de la vie
professionnelle pour qu'on puisse se
reconvertir on travaille sur la
formation continue effectivement il y a
des métiers où il n'est pas possible de
rentrer dans l'emploi 20 ans et d'y
aller jusqu'à 64 ans je suis comme vous
je suis pas complètement idiot et je
sais que c'est pas possible donc il faut
changer ça ok on est bien d'accord il y
a les carrières à cheveux il y a des
flammes et puis injustice de notre
système monsieur martinet et si vous
n'aviez pas manifester autant contre la
retraite peut-être celui-là aurait été
levé dès la première réforme de retraite
moi je connais quelqu'un qui a travaillé
dans la grande distribution pendant
trois ans comme
poissonnier il n'a pas cotisé
suffisamment
pour valider cette trimestre trois ans
perdus parce qu'une multiplication de
contrats précaires ça avec la retraite
par point vous le savez très bien
c'était impossible donc voyez il y a
plein le risque de blocage il est réels
aujourd'hui vous le craignez
moi je pense que les manifestants sont
dans la rue qui manifestent leur colère
c'est tout à fait normal et je le
conçois totalement c'est notre
démocratie il y a aucun souci pour
l'instant on n'est pas un point de
blocage on n'est pas du tout un point de
blocage et j'espère une chose c'est que
le débat démocratique se fera à
l'ensemble des national donc j'espère
que nos amis de la France insoumise ne
déposeront pas 75000 amendements comme
j'ai entendu dire et qu'on pourra
discuter au fond d'accord ça c'est le
premier point parce que la démocratie je
pense moi qu'elle se fait à l'Assemblée
nationale effectivement en tenant compte
de ce que dit la rue n'est pas
uniquement dans la
et ce sera le mot de la fin merci Bruno
milleniène et William Martinet d'avoir
accepté notre invitation plusieurs dates
sont à retenir concernant cette réforme
après avoir été développé dévoilé la
semaine dernière aux Français le texte
sera présenté au Conseil des ministres
lundi prochain le 23 janvier puis à
partir du 30 janvier il sera étudié en
commission à l'Assemblée nationale le
lundi 6 février tous les députés
pourront l'examiner cours en mars la
version validée par l'hémicycle sera
envoyé au sénateur qui pourront eux
aussi l'examiner plusieurs
allers-retours entre l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat sont à prévoir le
temps que les parlementaires s'accordent
sur la version définitive du texte le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron s'est engagé lors de ses vœux aux
Français le 31 décembre dernier à ce que
l'année 2023 soit celle de la réforme
des retraites il a fixé la fin de l'été
2023 comme
ultime échéance
on passe à un tout autre sujet on parle
à parler transport le nombre de
véhicules électriques et hybrides
rechargeable à tripler en 5 ans et cela
pourrait s'intensifier dans les années à
venir notamment avec la fin de la vente
de véhicule thermique 9 en 2035 mais
aussi face à l'explosion des prix du
carburant à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
l'agglomération a décidé de déployer des
bornes publiques de recharge pour
véhicules électriques et pour en parler
avec nous Grégory canalet journaliste de
la rédaction ces bornes de recherche
pour voiture électrique ont été lancées
officiellement ce matin à Élancourt et
elles sont baptisées Starsky ça fait
tout de suite penser à ça
[Musique]
le générique de cette série TV alors qui
parle je pense à tout le monde peut-être
tout le monde n'a pas vu Starsky et
Hutch mais je pense que le générique est
connu une série des années 70 Starsky et
Hutch qui suit les aventures de deux
policiers et de Bay City une ville
imaginaire en Californie David Starsky
et kennetou et pour cause 50 ans en
Yvelines l'agglomération c'est
directement inspiré de la série pour le
nom de son dispositif et pour la
communication tout autour on a vu il y a
même la voiture qui s'inspire de la
série Starsky et Hutch alors c'est un
réseau de bande de recharge électrique
Starsky pour véhiculer électrique les
voitures les motos mais aussi les vélos
ils s'appuie sur près de 30 points de
charge déjà présent à Maurepas
Coignières plaisir Villepreux et donc
depuis peu à Élancourt sur la place de
l'Hôtel de Ville cette dernière borne
est multimodale ça veut dire qu'on peut
y recharger deux véhicules à la fois
d'autres vont être installés dans les
prochains mois l'objectif pour
l'agglomération c'est de déployer
50 bornes elle a mis 2023 pour arriver
petit à petit à plus de 100 bornes
présentes sur le territoire opérationnel
et ce dans les 12 communes de
l'agglomération on a déjà avec les 28
bandes que nous avons on a pu regarder
collecter quelques datas donc c'est pas
des Data personnel mais les Data
d'utilisation qui nous permettent de
voir où il serait pertinent d'avoir des
bancs là où ça fonctionne ça fonctionne
moins on a aussi une un objectif de
service public donc principalement ce
sera basé dans le centre-ville parce
qu'on aussi besoin de faire fonctionner
le commerce donc et l'idée c'était
d'avoir aujourd'hui alors que c'était
que sur cinq villes d'étendre minimum
deux bandes de recharge dans les 12
villes du territoire c'est toujours vu
en relation en coopération effectivement
avec les mairies mais également les
habitants donc voilà c'est intéressant
que les habitants puissent se mobiliser
remonter les informations auprès des
mairies et alors comment ça fonctionne
concrètement Grégory la localisation de
La Borne elle peut se faire via les
applications mobiles de mobilité de
conduite et d'électromobilité
fraîchemile ou Milo voici quelques
exemples ou directement sur le site de
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines une carte
interactive vous permet de localiser
très rapidement la borne et d'en
connaître les caractéristiques une fois
sur place le déverrouillage de la borne
le paiement également se fait avec un
badge d'un opérateur de mobilité
compatible ou directement grâce à votre
carte bleue sans contact il est la
possibilité de brancher tout type de
prise en acier ou en décès et la
question qui nous intéresse le plus
Grégory combien ça coûte alors plusieurs
tarifs selon la puissance de charge
celle qui est déjà proposée par
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
c'est l'offre standard jusqu'à 22
kilowattheure votre véhicule se recharge
en 2h30 3h le coût 30 centimes d'euros
le kilowattheure dans la limite de 3
heures attention au-delà de 3 heures de
recharge une surfacturation s'applique
de 25 centimes par minute l'idée
d'assurer un certain roulement entre les
véhicules que ce ne soit pas juste des
places de stationnement mais bien des
places de recharge pour votre véhicule
électrique est très prochainement de
nouvelles la possibilité dans
l'agglomération l'offre Express qui ira
jusqu'à 50 kWh qui sera déployée dans un
second temps c'est à dire une recharge
entre une heure et 1h30 60 centimes
d'euros par kilowattheure 60 centimes de
rouge je répète par kilowattheure j'ai
un petit peu écorché dans la limite
d'une heure trente maximum et au-delà de
cette limite il y a une même
surfacturation qui s'applique de 25
centimes par minute et puis l'offre
boost elle qui sera déployée dans une
troisième phase jusqu'à 150 kWh et là
c'est Express Mathilde c'est très rapide
le véhicule se remplit la batterie se
remplit en 30 45 minutes les tarifs sont
les mêmes que pour l'offre Express un 60
centimes d'euros par kilowattheure avec
une surfacturation qui s'applique à
partir d'une heure trente d'utilisation
alors je crois que vous avez un bon plan
Grégory c'est de plutôt recharger la
nuit entre 22h et 8 heures du matin les
tarifs sont réduits de 30% ce qui donne
du 20 centimes le kilowattheure pour
l'offre standard 40 centimes pour les
offres boost et Express autre avantage
pas de surfacturation appliquée dans
cette tranche horaire merci beaucoup
Grégory canalet pour toutes ces
précisions on va faire un saut dans le
passé maintenant le 22 janvier
1963 la France et l'Allemagne signé le
traité de l'Élysée un accord visant à
réconcilier les deux pays à cette
occasion le lycée franco-allemand de Buc
célébré mardi dernier les 60 ans de ce
pacte au programme concert atelier
historique ou artistique proposé par les
élèves pour marquer cette semaine
anniversaire le reportage de Julien
Leroy
[Musique]
le chant de l'Allemagne résonne dans le
lycée franco-allemand de Buc instant
solennelle pour les mille et l'élève
venus célébrer les 60 ans du traité de
l'Elysée à corps signé entre le général
de Gaulle et le chancelier Adenauer le
22 janvier 1963 objectif sceller la
réconciliation entre la France et
l'Allemagne après plusieurs décennies de
conflits
nous avons été créés en tant que lycée
franco-allemand grâce à ce traité de
l'Elysée et ce qui nous semble très
important en tant qu'acteur du
franco-allemand c'est effectivement que
les dirigeants des deux pays fassent
vivre au quotidien ces échanges et ce
lien d'amitié ça fait 60 ans donc c'est
quelque chose qui dure surtout que la
France et l'Allemagne ça quand même une
histoire assez compliqué et que nous en
tant que jeune on soit aussi là pour se
remémorer ça ce mardi 17 janvier des
animations réalisées par les élèves du
CP jusqu'en terminal était proposé
concert joué par les ensembles musicaux
de l'école mais aussi analyse de parodie
sur les couples président chancelier on
a dû décrire et savoir enfin un peu
imaginer grâce à nos connaissances
notamment savoir
quelles étapes de l'histoire se passait
était représenté sur ses caricatures ils
sont je crois au lycée franco-allemand
de Buc extrêmement conscient aussi de
leur mission et de la nécessité de
continuer le travail et de rapprocher
les peuples les uns des autres cette
semaine de célébration se conclura ce
dimanche pour 40 élèves de terminale du
lycée franco-allemand de Buc ils seront
conviés à la Sorbonne à Paris pour la
célébration du traité avec Emmanuel
Macron et le chancelier olafiols
[Applaudissements]
le jeudi à tisse barrer nous propose une
chronique sur le bien-être animal alors
ATIS si on va parler d'une carte elle
s'affiche elle va s'afficher à l'écran
c'est inscrit j'ai un animal seul à la
maison alors en quoi ça consiste
concrètement à titre alors nous sommes
au mois de janvier c'est le mois où
c'est pas un mois très gai le taux de
mortalité est à son pic les malaises on
sort des fêtes on attrape plutôt des
infections par exemple vous attendez
votre train à jour de grève un malaise
peut vite arriver bouffé de chaleur vous
êtes transportés par les pompiers et
vous ne savez pas quand est-ce que vous
allez rentrer
donc cette carte votre animal va vous
attendre seule à la maison pendant des
heures et des longues heures et il ne
s'est pas encore lire et écrire et
pourra pas voir vos textos et donc du
coup cette carte elle sert à prévenir
les gens autour de nous mais qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire alors en fait cette
carte elle va éviter à votre animal de
d'avoir un risque de déjà d'être dans un
état de d'anxiété puisque les animaux
également on peuvent avoir une atteinte
psychologique cette carte donc j'ai créé
au niveau de la ville de Poissy qui se
présente comme celle-ci j'ai un animal
seul à la maison va vous permettre de
noter donc déjà le type d'animal est-ce
que c'est un chat un chien un acte les
nouveaux animaux de compagnie votre
lapin votre souris et dessus vous allez
y mettre donc les corps de nez de votre
gardien par exemple qui a les clés de
chez vous vous mettrez son nom son
numéro de téléphone et dès que donc vous
la mettez dans votre portefeuille dès
que les services sont bons ouvrez votre
portefeuille et ser un animal qui est à
la maison et qu'il prévienne donc vos
parents vos enfants et surtout ça va
également éviter des nuisances au niveau
du voisinage car croyez-moi que je suis
très souvent appelée pour dire qu'il y a
un chien qui pleure à la maison que
fait-on on fait intervenir la police
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait sinon on entend un chien qui
qui crie chez lui enfin qu'est-ce qu'on
comment est-ce qu'on intervient bah déjà
en fait on appelle vous appelez votre
alors ça dépend des villes vous avez des
référents de quartier vous faites une
petite enquête de voisinage qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé les voisins sont là sont
pas là j'ai eu le cas il y a deux
semaines
donc ensuite ils ont réussi à appeler un
proche qui est arrivé sinon c'est la
police qui défonce la porte qui fait
intervenir avec le maître chien qui voit
si l'animal est de bonne condition sinon
on prend on récupère l'animal
pour terminer ATIS cette carte on peut
la trouver où la récupérer où alors
cette carte vous pouvez la récupérer
dans certaines mairies à la mairie de
Poissy au niveau de l'accueil dans
d'autres mairies également bon pas dans
toutes les mairies et puis au niveau des
CCAS merci beaucoup à Athis on vous
retrouve dans deux semaines c'est bien
ça vous savez déjà de quoi vous allez
nous parler ou pas encore alors pas
encore
et bien à dans deux semaines on va
passer maintenant à notre page loisirs
[Musique]
et Ludivine canard nous a rejoint en
plateau bonsoir bonsoir alors vous allez
nous présenter les idées de sortie avant
ce weekend on commence par quoi alors il
y aura un événement ce week-end dans les
médiathèques de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines puisque les
nuits des lectures font leur grand
retour donc pour la deuxième année
consécutive cet événement est organisé
par le Centre national du livre et cette
année le thème c'est la peur alors
araignée sorcière fantôme seront trop au
programme des lectures pour les plus
petits de 0 à 3 ans seront proposés à la
médiathèque de Jean rouslo à Guyancourt
objectif jouer à se faire peur mais tout
en douceur pour les enfants un peu plus
grands de 2 à 5 ans des comptines et des
livres seront lus de 17h à 17h30 à
Maurepas et en milieu d'après-midi à
Trappes des lectures toutes tes lectures
tout public seront aussi auront aussi
lieu le samedi 21 janvier toute
l'après-midi à la médiathèque Anatole
France à Trappes ainsi qu'à la
médiathèque du canal à Montigny de 19
heures à minuit d'autres anim maléfique
seront aussi prévues photomaton de la
peur flashmob quiz ciné et réalité
virtuelle
parce que pardon la médiathèque du phare
à Maurepas propose quant à elle un apéro
lecture à partir de 8 ans des textes
pour vous faire frissonner seront lu
avoir haute et accompagné d'un verre
pour se lancer dans la nuit avec courage
pour la plupart des événements il est
conseillé de réserver auprès de la
médiathèque en question et autour de la
table je voulais savoir est-ce qu'il y a
un livre qui vous a fait frissonner
le meilleur des mondes d'aldos succès je
sais pas si vous le connaissez si vous
l'avez lu moi je l'ai lu peut-être au
collège et c'est un film pardon c'est un
livre qui m'a beaucoup marqué puisque il
a été créé en 1932 mais il évoque une
société assez futuriste ou les
nourrissons sont conçus dans des
éprouvettes et en fait on les traite
chimiquement donc il y a plusieurs
castes les castes supérieures qui seront
les dirigeants les satellite les castes
inférieurs qui seront qui occuperont des
postes peut-être plus manuels et en fait
dans ce livre le message c'est aussi de
peut-être nous faire réfléchir sur notre
société actuelle donc du coup il dénonce
notamment le génisme mais aussi le
consumérisme en fait beaucoup de traits
du quotidien et j'ai trouvé ça super
intéressant en tout cas la couverture du
livre fait un peu peur déjà
alors moi c'est pas vraiment un livre
qui fait peur c'est 1984 de George
Orwell Orwell même si à la fin il y a
une scène je vous spoile pas trop mais
il y a une scène de torture ou en fait
on utilise la phobie du personnage pour
torturer le personnage et c'est vrai que
ce passage là est assez glaçant mais
c'est pareil c'est un livre qui fait
réfléchir sur la société donc voilà
Grégory vous aviez aussi un réfléchit
beaucoup dans la rédaction c'est un
livre qui fait réfléchir un peu sur ce
quoi pourrait ressembler notre avenir
j'espère pas c'est une dystop forcément
connu que vous connaissez sans doute
hunger Games c'est une série de films
aussi qui a été donc adapté au cinéma de
Suzanne Collins c'est une trilogie il y
a même eu un quatrième livre qui est
sorti pour revenir un peu aux origines
de cette aventure et donc on est dans
les États-Unis du futur le pays
s'appelle Paname avec une dictature qui
est en place le pays est divisé en 12
districts et pour contrôler la
population par la peur il y a un jeu
télévisé qui s'appelle les Hunger Games
qui a lieu chaque année il y a 12
garçons 12 tribus filles 12 tribus
distribue fille 12 tribu garçons qui
sont envoyés pour participer à ce jeu et
donc la seule règle c'est de survivre
dans une arène donc de tous s'entretuer
il y a qu'un seul vainqueur dans les
Hunger Games et on va suivre les
aventures d'une fille du district numéro
12 qui s'appelle Katniss Everdeen qui
prend la place de sa sœur parce que sa
sœur était tirée au sort pour participer
à Hunger Games ça décide de prendre la
place de sa sœur et on va suivre les
aventures de de cette fille courageuse
qui va peu à peu va se dresser contre
cet état
dictatorial qui est Paname alors moi
j'ai vu les films Grégory mais j'ai pas
lu les livres est-ce que c'est assez
semblable ou est-ce qu'il y a quand même
des différences pour avoir être fan
aussi d'Harry Potter c'est vrai que sur
Harry Potter les fans les films je vais
y arriver ne colle pas au livre là je
trouve que sur Hunger Games ils ont été
plutôt fidèles par rapport au roman de
Suzanne Collins et d'ailleurs ça tombe
bien que vous parliez parliez des films
et une anecdote assez intéressante alors
je sais pas si c'est dans le film numéro
1 il me semble que c'est dans l'un des
des trois films il y a même eu deux
épisodes sur le troisième livre sur la
sur la révolte il y a une scène qui a
été tournée dans les Yvelines le la
résidence du président Snow qui est le
dictateur de de cette pseudo République
et Paname et bien c'est le château de
voisins à Rambouillet et donc c'est pas
voisin le bretonneuse c'est bien à
Rambouillet et donc on a eu 4000
Everdeen incarnés par par Jennifer
Lawrence qui est venu dans les Yvelines
pour interpréter cette scène que c'est
dans le quatrième film c'est en 4e film
donc là la révolte partie 2 voilà mais
voilà pour ce petit tour de table sur
nos livres qui nous ont fait frissonner
est-ce que il y a d'autres sorties à ne
pas rater ce weekend dans les Yvelines
Ludivine oui Mathilde le célèbre conte
d'Anderson la princesse au petit pois
est revisiter dans un spectacle de danse
au résonance multiple la chorégraphe
Maria Ciani l'adapte avec fantasy et
humour pour en offrir une version
décalée et ancrée dans notre époque un
spectacle qui s'adresse au plus jeune à
partir de 6 ans mais aussi au plus grand
puisqu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour être une
princesse et un autre classique ce jour
à ce samedi au théâtre Coluche de
plaisir oui je vous propose d'embarquer
dans le Titanic mais pas dans celui de
James Cameron mais dans celui d'Axel
Dray et ses acolytes les acteurs
s'emparent de l'histoire du tragique
naufrage pour en faire une grande
comédie musicale immersive le voyage
s'annonce mouvementé avec qui
s'entremêle au centre mêle les intrigues
les personnages et les lieux et on
termine avec un un spectacle un peu
particulier Ludivine oui l'illusionniste
et mentaliste Léo briève investit la
scène de la Merise à Trappes pour un
spectacle qui repousse les limites du
mentalisme mélangeant effets spéciaux
pyrotechnie et numéro originaux liées
à l'américaine parmi ses expériences et
ses numéros vous découvrirez une
expérience qui permettrait selon les
dires de libérer l'entièreté de notre
capacité cérébrale en bref préparez-vous
à une expérience inédite et tous vos
sens devrait être mobilisés on regarde
un extrait
dans la vie tout est une question de
perception vous auriez pu penser à
n'importe quel dessin et pourtant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en libérant l'intégralité de nos
capacités cérébrales serions-nous
capables d'accomplir des choses
extraordinaires
[Musique]
merci beaucoup les divines canards pour
toutes ces idées de sortie et alors si
vous ne savez toujours pas quoi faire ce
week-end Michael el mis Doro et Patrick
Jacques de dixmu dont sont allés faire
un petit tour du côté de
Maisons-Laffitte les deux journalistes
de la rédaction de TV 78 ils se sont
rendus à Maisons-Laffitte du coup pour
découvrir les spécialités de la commune
je vous laisse regarder
[Musique]
depuis de nombreuses années la ville de
Maisons-Laffitte est surnommée la Cité
du cheval en raison de son importante
activité équestre selon la légende il y
aurait plus de chevaux que d'habitants
dans la commune le champ de courses a
été inauguré en 1800 à 78 ce qui stimula
les activités hippiques ici dans la
commune et de nombreux entraîneurs sont
venus à s'installer nous allons
justement rencontrer un
[Musique]
pour commencer cette journée à
Maisons-Laffitte je suis avec Didier à
Prodhomme entraîneur équestre ici à
Maisons-Laffitte alors Didier Prudhomme
quelle est l'histoire et quel ici dans
cette commune bah les courses hippiques
ont découlé de
de petits challenges entre noble qui
faisait courir des chevaux entre eux et
puis les Anglais ont amené la
compétition
hippique et depuis ça n'a jamais cessé
sur Maisons-Laffitte donc c'est une
commune baptisée la cité du cheval
est-ce qu'il y a plus de chevaux que
d'habitants c'est un peu la légende
qu'on dit sinon non non il y a jamais eu
par petit il y a très longtemps
mais là à l'heure actuelle il y a à peu
près une moyenne de 500 chevaux 500
pur-sangs qui sont en train sur
Maisons-Laffitte et puis vous avez tous
les chevaux de club hippiques vous avez
les chevaux de concours hippiques voilà
et puis je pense que la ville de maison
Lafitte est en partie sur la reconquête
donc
dans quelques années le nombre va
augmenter
[Musique]
après un chocolat chaud comptoir des
deux frères nous remontons l'avenue de
Longueuil pour découvrir l'épicerie de
Longueuil créée en 1880 derrière ses
vitrines se cachent une vraie caverne
d'Ali Baba pour les gourmands ici on
peut y trouver des fromages fermiers des
produits régionaux de la charcuterie du
chocolat des confiseries mais pour voir
le plus impressionnant il faut descendre
de quelques mètres dans cette cave à vin
presque unique en France on retrouve
près de 3200 références et des centaines
de bouteilles conservées certains
amateurs n'hésitent pas à faire des
dizaines de kilomètres pour trouver des
bouteilles rares
Maisons-Laffitte est aussi une ville qui
a vu passer de nombreuses célébrités
Voltaire à ses journées dans le château
de Maisons-Laffitte en 1723 Jean Cocteau
le célèbre cinéaste résidait place Sully
le chanteur Demis Roussos avait une
maison avec une salle de bain démesurée
construite dans du marbre place Napoléon
plus récemment limitateur Nicolas
Canteloup vient régulièrement dans la
ville pour faire du cheval et pour les
fans d'Harry Potter Emma Watson la
célèbre Hermione a vécu ici dans cette
ville yvelinois jusqu'à ses 5 ans
[Musique]
alors est-ce que ça vous donne envie
d'aller visiter maison Lafitte autour du
plateau moi oui enfin j'habite à côté
donc je connais déjà et c'est vraiment
une superbe ville vous connaissez pas du
tout Maisons-Laffitte j'ai appris des
choses j'ai appris des choses d'autres
réactions
Lafitte c'est vrai qu'on connaît nous en
tant que journaliste des Yvelines cette
cité du cheval voilà c'est c'est son
surnom mais il y a d'autres choses à
découvrir et voilà Michael nous fait
découvrir tous ces petits secrets ça
permet de connaître un peu mieux cette
ville en tout cas si vous voulez voir le
reportage en entier sachez qu'il est
déjà disponible sur notre site Internet
et nos réseaux sociaux on va passer
maintenant au quiz avec vous Nicolas
dandry alors c'est à l'occasion de la
Nuit de la lecture vous allez nous
plonger dans les écrivains célèbres qui
ont été deux passages dans les Yvelines
vous avez pu découvrir quelques
écrivains déjà donc dans ce reportage
bon on va voir il y a de nombreux
écrivains qui sont passés dans les
Yvelines et d'abord un certain Marcel
Alain né en 1885 qui a vécu et qui est
mort en 1969 à Saint-Germain en Lay il a
écrit des livres comme les mystères du
métro ou Monsieur Personne il est
surtout connu pour avoir créé son avec
son co-auteur Pierre Souvestre
impersonnage emblématique de la
littérature on le connaît aussi ce
personnage parce que c'est un personnage
de film alors de quel personnage
s'agit-il il va falloir nous donner
quelques indices je peux vous dire non
non je peux vous dire que ce personnage
et bien on le voit notamment et il a
combattu face au commissaire Juve qui a
été interprété par Louis de Funès et ça
c'était dans les années 60
un personnage masqué
peut-être que Ludivine qui est juste
derrière à la réponse
peut-être oui c'est ça
et bien Ludivine à la bonne réponse et
regarder cette extrait c'est Fantômas
[Musique]
et un certain professeur le fait
professeur le sait non le professeur le
fait c'est moi et je vois trois
professeurs Lefebvre avec Louis de Funès
[Musique]
voilà il y a une quinzaine de films avec
Fantômas Fantômas qui est interprété par
Jean Marais et pas heureux
deuxième question un peu plus facile
est-ce que vous reconnaissez et bien ces
images
la maison Triolet dragon bon voilà ça
tombe voilà bon j'ai même pas besoin de
poser la question puisque Grégory a
donné la réponse effectivement Louis
Aragon et Elsa Triolet ont vécu dans
cette maison et aujourd'hui vous pouvez
la visiter cette maison et découvrir le
quotidien de Louis Aragon et d'Elsa
Triolet qu'on voit en photo
effectivement de
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines Grégory bravo
troisième question il est connu pour
être le premier auteur d'un roman de
science-fiction qui s'appelait les états
enfin qui s'appelle toujours les États
et empires de la Lune et du soleil mais
surtout pour avoir inspiré le personnage
principal d'une des pièces les plus
célèbres du répertoire français qu'elle
écrivain est né en 16 en 1619 pardon et
a passé son enfance au château de
mauvière à Saint-Forget alors pour vous
donner un indice c'est un personnage
célèbre d'une pièce de théâtre et qui a
inspiré justement le personnage de cette
pièce de théâtre question assez
compliqué
je donne ma langue au chat
si je vous dis de mon Rostand
de l'écrivain savignan de Cyrano qui a
inspiré le personnage de Cyrano de
Bergerac et qui est et bien qui a passé
son enfance au château de mauvière à
Saint-Forget c'est tout près d'ici c'est
du côté et bien c'est juste après
château fort
quatrième question regardez ces images
nous sommes à l'abbaye de Port-Royal
Deschamps
voilà l'abbaye de Pont Royal Deschamps
donc juste à côté de manie des hameaux
le château de la Madeleine à Chevreuse
voilà des images des courses de vélo
ce n'est pas une erreur de montage ça je
vous le dis mais la question ben c'est
la suivante quel est le célèbre drame
dramaturge et bien qui est réuni dans
toutes ces images
c'est réuni dans toutes ces images ces
images font référence à un célèbre
dramaturge français qui est ce célèbre
d'armature
par rapport oui oui
Jean Racine effectivement j'en racine
donc la
course de vélo vous avez vu à l'image
s'appelle la course de la Jean Racine
parce que en fait j'en racine a vécu
pendant longtemps à l'abbaye de
Port-Royal Deschamps et passer notamment
pour aller jusqu'au château de la
Madeleine il y avait le chemin de Jean
Racine que on peut emprunter toujours à
l'heure actuelle et donc la course de
vélo qui a lieu que vous avez vu ces
images c'est dans la vallée de Chevreuse
cette course de vélo s'appelle la Jean
Racine c'est la course de vélo qui m'a
évolué du côté de l'abbaye de Port-Royal
cinquième question regardez ces images
nous sommes à la Villa Viardot à
Bougival
alors quel romancier nouvelle liste et
dramatures je n'ai en 1818 en Russie
auteur de père et fils ou de mémoire
d'un chasseur et dont on a publié
récemment les correspondances avec
Flaubert intitulée je n'ai pas les nerfs
assez solides pour vivre dans ce monde a
vécu dans cette ville là
[Musique]
Bougival Pauline Viardot et en fait
c'était le mari hein tu as gagné non
exactement
Ivan tourgayer
écrivain russe donc était marié à Madame
mais c'est vrai qu'on en avait beaucoup
parlé au moment du Loto du patrimoine de
la Villa Vierge sont issues de ce
reportage en plus il mentionne les
sources de mes images Grégory bravo
c'est les archives de tv78 aussi
dernière question
des nouvelles images regardez cette
demeure un très joli château il est
situé au Port-Marly dans un espace dans
un espace à un forestier un peu caché
est-ce que vous pouvez me dire quel
écrivain a vécu dans ce château
c'est le château de Monte-Cristo
d'Alexandre Dumas qui a vécu dans cette
demeure voilà bon il va falloir réviser
[Musique]
le jeudi mais je tire ces infos de
notamment de cet ouvrage voilà qui a été
réalisé par le Conseil départemental des
Yvelines et donc qui répertorie des
personnes célèbres qui sont passées ou
pion vécu dans le département des
Yvelines et puis je remercie aussi
Patrice carmouz notre notre directeur
d'information qui m'a donné mais
aiguillé vers certaines réponses voilà
merci beaucoup Nicolas dandry est-ce que
vous voulez savoir la météo de demain et
la météo de ce weekend est-ce que ça
vous intéresse
alors la météo de demain c'est tout de
suite
demain matin le soleil sera bien présent
sur l'ensemble du département au niveau
des températures il fera 0° à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Versailles et
moins 1 degré à Rambouillet mais les
ressentis seront aux alentours de -3
dans l'après-midi le beau temps sera
toujours au rendez-vous au rendez-vous
au niveau des températures comptées 6
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 5 à Houdan et
Versailles et 4 à Rambouillet pour la
météo de ce week-end samedi matin à les
températures seront comprises entre 0 et
1 degré sur tout le département Météo
France annoncent des éclaircies même
temps pour l'après-midi il fera à peine
plus chaud compter 3 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et Houdan
deux petits degrés à Rambouillet
dimanche des températures négatives vous
attendent à peu près partout sauf du
côté de Mantes-la-Jolie sur le reste du
Département et l'État annoncé - 1 degré
du côté du ciel sont attendus des
éclaircies et pas de grands changements
dimanche après-midi pour la température
comptez 1 degré dans le nord du
département 0 dans le centre et - 1
degré dans le sud voilà vous savez tout
sur la météo de demain et de ce week-end
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi jusqu'au bout avec nous
je vous souhaite une belle soirée sur
tv78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]
et c'est là ouais tout de suite